hey guys it's dr. Berg here in this
video I want to show you what's behind
sleep apnea sleep apnea is not really a
sleeping problem it's a sleeping symptom
it's an air obstructive pathway problem
people sleep apnea can't breathe because
there's something obstructing the
pathways of air getting into the lungs
so if you're not breathing you're not
going to sleep so that's why they use
the little CPAP machines to force air in
there and then you can sleep better
right there's a couple things that I
wanted I want to show you what's behind
the scenes and number one if you have a
sleep apnea usually you have a
collapsing of the back part of the sinus
back through the throat area and it
starts to what's called atrophy and
atrophy is kind of a sagging drooping
tissue that can then obstruct the
breathing pathways and it can come from
many different things people say it's
obesity but there's a lot of skinny
people that have this and a lot of fat
people that don't have it so it's not
necessarily the obesity that does it but
you could have some excess fat back
there that's possible but we don't
normally accumulate fat in the back of
our sinuses so that's very unlikely
but the things that people are doing to
get fat usually are causing other
problems in the body and that's the drug
that's the connection
number one the immediate thing that I
would do if I were you of you if you
have this is change your diet one is
that you want to avoid milk any milk
products ice cream and even cheese
because that will create a swelling back
here right off the bat and anything that
creates inflammation will be a problem
so allergies food allergies are a big
problem sugar is a big problem because
sugar will cause swelling of the
different tissues it's very inflammatory
and if someone has this problem before I
do anything I will change their diet get
them off the sugar
get them off wheat grains that would be
breads pastas or crackers biscuits
waffles and milk and then see if it
clears up
it might just clear up and they might
have allergies
because during seasonal allergies when
your sinuses are all clogged up well
that's going to also create a problem
with this as well if you have allergies
hives asthma anything like that
one of the best remedies would be royal
jelly and that is a kind of a something
to get in the beehives where it's a
little excretion of a fluid that the
bees put to help grow the queen bee to
help to fertilize that and there's
something in there that is really good
to help neutralize allergies so that's
one thing I would recommend if you have
a problem with allergies to the sinuses
and then send us congestion I would go
after the eating first and then see if
that just doesn't just clear it up and
then high cortisol that's high stress
that can also shrink a nerve that's
connected to your brain stem when the
cranial nerves that goes to the back of
the sinuses and so one of the symptoms
of high cortisol or being on prednisone
or cortisone for different conditions
that can create a problem with you
developing this condition so if it's
that problem I would recommend my
cortisol support product which basically
what it does is supports inflammation it
supports adrenal and helps to support
the deeper cause of that and that will
help reduce inflammation and then you'll
start breathing better if you have
allergies year round that could be a
fungus growing in your sinuses because
you had a history of antibiotics but it
can also come from other things so if
that's the case then I would work on
your gut established friendly flora
build up the good bacteria in your gut
and that will definitely help this okay
the last thing I'm going to recommend is
apple cider vinegar why because just by
dropping dropping the pH of your body
just a little bit with apple cider vinegar
like a teaspoon in some water every day
it will instantly increase your oxygen
carrying capacity through your body and
you'll actually breathe better and you
should just try it to see if that's that
works for you I
there's one more thing I would do as
well a lot of times people like at night
have a hard time breathing in general so
having plants in the room will increase
your oxygen so in my room I have several
plants and I find that if I sleep with a
plant next to me I actually actually
breathe better so that's just you know
try to sleep in a greenhouse right
you'll just have more oxygen or even in
a thunderstorm you get more oxygen in
the air so those are some tips to help
sleep apnea and I will see you in the
next video